[Music]
imagine we have to walk from one place
to another for this our brain thinks
about the movement instructs the
respective muscles and helps us perform
the task this is what we know as a
voluntary activity now tell me do we
need to remind ourselves post sometime
that we have to inhale and exhale a or
do we remind our heart to beat and pump
blood no right that just happens without
our notice these are the examples of
involuntary activities involuntary
activities are mostly the crucial ones
that occur within us and which help us
sustain life take this activity of
breathing for example isn't it extremely
important if we don't breathe then how
will all the cells in our body obtain
the necessary oxygen for survival and
how will the toxic carbon dioxide be
released out also how will the cells
derive energy if the food molecules are
not broken down so overall respiration
is extremely important now tell me one
thing our breathing and respiration the
same thing I'm sure your answer will be
yes but that's not true let's understand
what exactly the difference between the
two is to begin with I want you to
answer one simple question how do we get
the energy to perform all activities
most of us will answer from the food we
eat right well that's partially correct
the food we eat is the source of energy
which means that the energy is stored or
locked inside the food in order to
unlock or derive the energy from it the
food needs to be broken down and this
requires oxygen so we can say that the
process in which the food is broken down
in the cells with the help of oxygen to
release energy is called respiration
and how is it different from breathing
then well breathing does not involve
breakdown of food molecules inside the
cells
in fact breathing is purely the exchange
of gases oxygen and carbon dioxide to be
precise so the activity of inhalation
and exhalation is breathing whereas
deriving energy from food molecules with
the help of oxygen is respiration does
this mean that breathing is a part of
respiration absolutely
breathing is a smaller process which is
considered as a part of the larger
process of respiration let's once again
go through the definition of respiration
it's the process in which the food is
broken down in the cells with the help
of oxygen to release energy and how do
the cells get oxygen it's due to
breathing right that's why we say that
breathing is a part of respiration now
the next important thing we need to
understand is the types of respiration
hold on isn't a simple process how can
there be types in this then well
respiration is classified in types based
on the location where it occurs there
are three types of respiration to be
precise external internal and cellular
respiration external respiration is the
one which occurs at the nasal level the
oxygen from the surrounding air is
brought inside the nasal cavity and the
carbon dioxide is given out this is
called external respiration which
involves interaction with the exterior
world in other words external
respiration is sometimes used
synonymously with breathing next in the
list is internal respiration as the name
suggests the one which occurs internally
or inside the body to be precise when
the oxygen from the air reaches the
lungs it gets transported to the blood
similarly carbon dioxide from the blood
is given out in the lungs which travels
later to the nasal area the oxygen then
travels throughout the body and is
delivered to the cells and the carbon
dioxide is similarly taken away this
exchange of gases that occurs inside the
lungs
and the cells is called internal
respiration and last on the list is
cellular respiration don't we know this
the name says it all the process in
which oxygen is used to break down the
food molecules by the cells is called
cellular respiration many times internal
and cellular respiration are confused
with each other but now the difference
is very clear external respiration is
where gaseous exchange occurs at the
nasal area internal respiration is where
gaseous exchange occurs between the
lungs blood and the cells while cellular
respiration is restricted to the cells
only so is this seen in all organisms -
all organisms have this similar system
well it's obvious that the mechanisms
will vary from habitat to habitat and
from organism to organism so how are the
mechanisms different let's find that out
in the upcoming video
[Music]
you